dink-dink welcome back to the gingely
vodka always be ready I was having quiet
I could hear I could hear the nothing
that's what prompted me to make noise
yes that's you and I in a nutshell you
hear me having quiet time so you need to
fill that time with noise if you ain't
making noisy making welcome welcome back
to the podcast this episode is brought
to you by Squarespace the all-in-one
platform to help you build a fantastic
and beautiful website in a very easy
manner right now check it out by going
to Squarespace that's squ a RESP AC e
comm / gin Angeline save 10% of your
first purchase of a website or domain or
just give it a try with a free trial
they have 24/7 customer support very
very awesome platform also guys me Andy
Leone's the wonderful company that
decided to come out with an otter onesie
these are otters and they're holding
hands and they're holding hands while
they float on their back so they don't
drift away from each other while they
sleep this is their new onesie they're
coming out with new ones these seemingly
all the time now and the ones these are
made of the same material that the
undies are made of which is the micro
model fabric only onesie Julian can wear
because he gets too hot and everything
else that's ever been invented for all
my peeps out there that run hot look no
further for a onesie that you can wear
it is so breathable and wonderful the
guys go to meet undies dot-com /
annejulien save 15% off your first pair
free shipping and 100 100% satisfaction
guarantee more on that later
Thank You sponsors thank you sponsor
what do we have here just two of my
lovely quiet time friends Julian oh no
no no no no no please don't yell into my
plans I'm just saying I know okay for
those of you that are listening and
cannot see right now we are joined by
two of my best friends I want to
emphasis by saying Jenna has been
working very hard
on being a responsible and also a very
advocate plant owner what does that mean
advocate plant I don't know I was just
kind of think of offense but a
responsible and active plant owner
you're getting new plants every single
day oh not every day oh my god well
every single day that we have time and
go to the plant store well because I
have a very specific vision
my point is she hasn't really talked
about it or showed it on anything yet
besides the stream a couple times
because she want I mean you want to make
sure you can take care of them and do a
good job before you kind of show it off
so I got well I was waiting until after
spring like or summer after they have a
little growing season you know also half
of them might be invisible because we're
on a green screen so these are the backs
which should show up anyway my point is
that you can do a really sick job and a
lot of people don't even see the
behind-the-scenes of you doing your
research and getting these plants but I
do it's very cool so I'm very much a
beginner I want to do like a plant tour
and I want to share my love for plants
but I'm trying it to jump the gun I'm a
beginner for real like it's it's been a
lot to learn and so I don't want to be
like hey guys welcome to my plant tour
and there's plants there that are just
like [ __ ] dying by the way I haven't
killed any planets except for one giant
pothos also I haven't cared let me play
there in case you guys were wondering I
feel like you might have been was enjoy
julian has been very patient and
accepting of my plant obsession and I'm
very lucky that he lets me do it because
it's getting its it will get out of hand
yeah it's so easy to just all of a
sudden spiral into madness well I think
we'll be able I'll be able to identify
that before it happens but so far what's
the get mad at it makes you happy it
makes the house look more beautiful it
makes the air more more clean and
breathable like noticeably better yeah
it's uh like we just built a room
downstairs and put it together with
these plants in this chair it looks like
a Pinterest room now like why would I
complain about that yeah well so
like I watched so many plant videos on
YouTube and I have a lot of people that
I like watching because it's super
relaxing to me I don't know what
happened like I grew up with plants as a
little girl like my mom had Christmas
cactus she had pothos she had spider
plants and I would just walk around with
this little jug of water and water the
plants every week like was one of my
chores but like I always sort of thought
that they were dowdy and like not cute
you know what she's really cute she's
vegged today
she's shaped like an egg she looks like
an egg she walks like an egg she's the
same color as an egg brown hmm I always
thought that they were like kind of
dowdy
you know like I just didn't appreciate
them I thought that they looked matronly
you know yeah cuz my mom would have like
macrame planters were matronly
well I just they always reminded me of
our dining room which we didn't really
eat in that was like full of this like
really dark wooden furniture like not a
lot of light reminded me of just like
vapid void like no Sun winters with all
these windows and it's [ __ ] freezing
in there and I have to go around with
this stupid little thing of water and
like reach up super high and then it
starts spilling on the ground I don't
want to clean it up off the ground no if
I just like swishing around my foot a
little and a little hard like I didn't I
didn't like doing it and I didn't
appreciate that and my dad had a giant
Christmas cactus too or Thanksgiving
cactus whatever you call them yeah and
they flower mm-hmm they're really pretty
and like in the winter you would have
these little like red or pink blooms and
I was like when I was little I was
always like you know I grew up in a
place where there's no [ __ ] plants
that live in the winter except for your
pine trees [ __ ] and I'm looking at this
beautiful green plant with pink flowers
indoors and upstate New York where
there's no [ __ ] Sun for like eight
months of the year and I'm looking at it
and I'm going what a [ __ ] ugly plant
[Laughter]
kid that didn't appreciate the beauty of
a living plant inside of your home and
how spectacular it is so fast forward a
bunch of years later what sparked your
obsession with well not obsession but
like interest and hobby in getting
plants for your new house well so a we
got a bunch of plants when we lived in
our old house and even when I was in
college I had like fake palms because
I've always liked the way that like you
know a palm tree looks to me something
that makes a really exciting plant it's
something that just does not [ __ ]
belong here you know what I'm saying but
like for me now that I live in Southern
California a bird of paradise is like
still the prettiest thing I could ever
imagine
you know because you just don't see them
they're good looking I can't I can't get
over their leaves their flowers what is
that what is that what is that okay I
mean I grew up with those I know you did
it's incredible yeah yeah you grew up
with like a lot of there's just plants
growing see where I grew up everything
drops its leaves and it it looks like
it's actually dead so just like your
soul on the inside when you haven't seen
the Sun in [ __ ] forever side note I
have to put you on blast me what I'm
someone who comes from the tundra yeah
he likes to always talk about how
horrible and it is it's the tide a
durable yeah okay I open the door for
five seconds at night and you lose your
goddamn mind I'm not dressed for the
cold I'm not dressed for the cold I'm
wearing my pajamas with no bra on
there's a dress going up my shirt and
you just open the door inside to relax
the dogs need to go outside what do you
want me to do they can go outside but
sometimes you don't tell me and I don't
move away from the door and get a big
draft I'm cold I like sometimes cold as
cold as I can't believe how quickly you
yell at me the door was open for three
seconds it's cold I'm not dressed for
that I just wanted to put you on glasses
yeah well when you live in a cold place
you dress for the cold and we're not
like walking we have to drive there's
like first of all there's nothing where
are you going it's just like the other
side of a [ __ ] big open field mmm no
cool anyways I will say though you you
do make fun of me sometimes for being a
little warm la boy but yeah you are not
as bad as some people who whether shame
people who grew up in warm climates I'm
not trying to weather shame I just think
it's funny whenever we travel somewhere
cold like you enroll no not being wrong
I try I am good now I took a couple
practice runs like in kinder recently
yes you are better now but like we
literally went to Santa Barbara one time
and you didn't bring a jacket or it was
like 40 degrees at home who's pointing
is a who now we were in Santa Barbara we
couldn't buy anything I was freezing
we had like just started dating and
Julian was like let's drive somewhere
let me take this area but yeah let's
ride to Santa Barbara he didn't bring a
jacket and it was breezy that's on the
ocean yeah no it gets cold it a night
yeah and that's that was like classic
young me like and I did be fine I'm
always hot I don't forgot for reason I
forgot my wallet so he couldn't even
like could go anywhere do anything yeah
well I think we got like tacos and then
like at home yeah it was really fun I
never meant anyways anyways yes you're
better about the cold well since we're
exchanging compliments you're better
about not whether shaming me so I'm
really bad in the heat though I get like
cranky and I can't do anything yes
well yeah I mean my body's not used to
it well the heat out here not not isn't
ain't no baby heat man this is like I
still wear pants in a dry Valley heat
yeah I still wear pants in it I know you
do I know you know what's weird is I
feel like and this might be wrong just
like my my bad memory but I feel like
last winter like a year ago now wasn't
really we didn't have really whether it
was just kind of like moderate there
wasn't there was no rain there was like
it snowed here recently it snowed in LA
like last week
like 10 like 5 10 miles from us yeah
yeah so we had like this winter
like normal weather where it was like
didn't really dip dip below 50 degrees
even at night and then summer comes
you're like [ __ ] already but this year
we've had a lot of cold days and a lot
of the night it's a lot of rain so when
summer comes I feel like it'll be a
little more welcomed the end of my story
please subscribe to my book club mm-hm
anyway anyways oh oh oh what Oh was that
distracting my anecdote on our podcast
you know what lay on that on the table I
want to be the center of attention
Julian just pointed to a small orange
cushion on the table that marbles likes
to sit on think we should play this game
where I every every time I do something
physical and outrageous on the podcast
you have to like in an NPR voice
describe just for you it's not always
that marble chooses a cushion and
decides that it's a good cushion but he
right away decided that he liked that
one he likes it because he said it's
breathable good boy he was like I'm
gonna go pet that person's dog without
asking ya then I'm gonna open his mouth
and try and look at his teeth and
Brian's like don't do that we don't like
that nice believe it or not it's from an
episode of Breaking Bad
early on when when Aaron Paul's
character is going to his like drug
dealer friends is the character that
would say Poochie there's this like pit
pitbull like really angry I don't even
know might have been a pit bull no it
was like a German Shepherd something
really like angry like drug dealer dog
and he just goes Poochie
so now that's how I
to her no she's too pure for your
garbage she likes no you enjoy garbage
from me she likes my nonsense
no interfaces today she actually likes
it if you were burped on your dog's face
yeah that sounds violated the dogs love
it PG PG like nothing Marvel's night
Kermit just PG cuz she's nasty and food
driven you guys belong together
yes thank you she's my dog she's like
she's nasty she's sweet I'm very sweet
say for this podcast you see it very
sweet and but when food comes out not
like literally everything goes dark
except for the food and then I'm just
like focused it's like a hyper focused
ability we have she is the same way she
turns into a literal different animal
when there's food I've seen her foam at
the mouth for food
she might be feral should I get her
looked at she's okay anyway that wasn't
a tangent anyways I want to talk about
plants plants be like water me oh my god
what is wrong with you you make me
[Laughter]
distracted decisions
all right so tell us about this one and
why we have it because this is
definitely not a plan I've seen before
you got one okay well I wanted to don't
talk about how I got there because I had
like fake plants in college because I I
just thought that I didn't do any
research like I thought that you had to
water them like every day I thought
having a plant was like a big commitment
I don't think that's uncommon at all I
think a lot of people think that yeah
like it's too hard oh my god I'm at home
enough for a plant like you know
meanwhile I have two dogs but like
definitely can't have a plant that's too
difficult you know that's what I thought
and then even in our old place we did
have a vegetable garden we did have a
bunch of succulents all of which died
most of the kale I swear just took over
that garden that will we never ever gave
that whole thing a fair shot we like we
bought we planted like a little bit of
basil a little bit of K a little bit
like cilantro scallions whatever and we
didn't do anything besides water it a
couple times and just like let it and
the Kayla Kayla took over over grew all
the planters and then something started
eating the kale yeah like an animal will
come and I need the kale yeah I have a
hard time growing anything that's like
food yeah it's like just bugs
it's a different beast for sure yeah
it's definitely hard and I fortunately
haven't had to any like pests yet with
my indoor plants I know that it's
eventually something I'll have to deal
with but you know just once it happens
it's sort of like you just have to take
care of it but I didn't find some
millipedes in pod the other night
whatever anyways so I always thought
that it was just like something that I
had to take care of constantly and it
didn't realize how little work most of
them are and like they like when you
don't do stuff to them so once we bought
our house and I knew that wasn't have to
move plants which is a [ __ ] nightmare
because they're alive you know yeah and
they get stressed out so stressed out I
was like okay let me get some good like
low light air purifying house plants
because now
here yeah and we're not gonna move and
I'm super excited and let's get some
plants so I and I assumed everywhere in
our house is just low light cuz I'm
scared and I don't understand what light
is you know I'm just like I don't know
seems dark I don't know you know I'm
saying fair enough
I'm I wasn't the type of person that was
like assumed every plant could live in
my house Feroze the other way to be fair
our last place and the place before that
so dark horrible way so [ __ ] dark
pitch-black
yes comparatively look we have great
light here not to say that our life
absolutely it's amazing and it's the
winter right now and you know there's
less Sun but we still get a lot of Sun
here so it's been easier for me than if
we lived somewhere like where I
previously lived where in the winter
your plants really start to suffer
because there's just not a lot of light
this going some of them go dormant yeah
so I started with like a snake plant and
a zz plant and a couple things like that
like easy easy indoor plants and we
brought them home and they just [ __ ]
took off like they were so happy and I
realized that I only thing yeah well I
realize that I only needed to water them
like those particular plants when their
soils like [ __ ] dry and I'm like okay
so you're saying I just sit here and
enjoy you for the majority of the time
and don't do anything do you it's
amazing wow that was also one of the
most surprising pets for me too when you
told me that and like I think like I
said this is I feel like this is a
common misconception is like a lot of
houseplants are very difficult to take
care of which they're really not like
you just need to learn the basics but
like yeah you let most of these get
their soil completely dry well not
completely but yet a lot of them so one
thing that helped me a ton was getting
just it it literally has a meter that
says dry and wet and I stick it in the
soil it's like my favorite thing to do
in the morning to get some coffee and to
walk around all my plants and I just
check all their soil
I see how they're doing I wipe down some
leaves maybe and you know most of the
time I don't have to water any plants
and it's not like on a schedule it's not
like once
week I water them and just water them as
they need it and it you know takes well
at this point I have over 50 plants I
think so
it's it takes me a little longer now
than it did but it's just you know 10-15
minutes in the morning to go check
around and take off any dead leaves
who's your favorite plant don't do that
surely about these two up for a reason
so well yes I love them but um my for
the most part most of my plants are
super easy but then I fell down the
rabbit hole which is why this is a
dangerous hobby because first of all
this plant is a Hoya which is one of my
favorite like I don't know species I
guess of plants because their leaves are
like thick and waxy they don't have like
leaf drop the they're just sort of like
cool-looking they look baked they're
called the wax plant or a wax flower and
they [ __ ] bloom yeah if you give them
the right conditions which is cooler
temperatures at night and good Sun but
yeah they have like a really interesting
shape that they hold well yeah there's
like there's a million different types
so once you find a plant that you like
then you start finding out how many
other types of them there are and now
you're now you're sucked in now you're
sucked into the rabbit hole how many
holes do you have you have a lot this is
the Jolla Cardinal compacta I also have
the crispa or I think the variegated
version voya compacta crispa I think
it's hi Chris whatever I have the very
good version of this as well very good
it is very gated it well I don't know
the technical generally it's got white
on it it's like I what I'm assuming is
like an albino type of plant almost it
needs a little more love a little more
light a little more care but like people
go nuts for them because they're
beautiful so like if you look up like a
variegated monstera delicioso with it
like it looks like a watercolor painting
yeah it's insane like some of them are
just so insane and you have to be really
careful with their light needs because
they'll
it whatever I'm a beginner so the thing
that helped me the most is if a plant
doesn't seem like he's doing that well I
just give him a little more light yeah
and they can't have any direct light
because any light that just beams down
on them will probably you know burn them
outside yeah yeah they'll burn but
especially since it's February right now
if a plant is struggling I just try and
move them to a spot where they're gonna
get more light and I've had success in
caring for them that way
but how many choice do I have I have
obovata obovata crinkle eight Cardosa
or his might be a billy a lot or
something like that
a crimson princess the one that has
variation from the inside mm-hmm and
then the outside is that crimson Queen
yeah I've been forcing Julian to I've
been studying but there's a couple of
boys that I really want but I need to
wait till springtime so I can maybe
order them so anyways this the the whole
like getting plants and enjoying them
has been really fun because they were
all like sort of normal plants I love my
rubber trees I love I got a um fiddly
fig that everyone seems to struggle with
but like I'm having a great you were so
nervous about that thing you guys he's
gonna die who's gonna die and then it's
like thrive so well because some of the
tips that I read online is like if
you're not sure about a plant or if it's
you know might be a little difficult for
you which everything in the beginning is
difficult because I don't know what it
means I don't know what it wants
I can't tell or if it's like you know
specific species of plant or whatever
you're not used to it so you don't know
like like a pathos pothos or you know a
lot of plants out there we want to be
watered they like wilt a little and at
first you're like oh my god it's dying
its dead I'm killing it but it's just
its way of being like hey water me and
then after you give it some water it
perks right that and like certain things
like the plant can do will say stop
watering me Riley oh yeah yeah like if
it starts well this is a this plant
loves high humidity so he might have a
little bit of crispy on his leaves from
the humidity but most plants will turn
brown yeah our bedroom has turned into a
little
a little bit of a rainforest I didn't
see that I didn't do they now have to
humidify to maintain a humidity level of
50 percent humidity which is about 15 to
20 percent higher than the rest of the
house I don't know China it's nice I'm
not complaining but it is significantly
nicer than it was it is nicer we have a
humidity monitor downstairs and it's
like a regularly at 30% like it's dry
it's drying like you're throwing dry we
live in a dry dry climate yeah
plants don't like that plants are like
especially the ones that specifically
need humidity
yeah I'm sure this my baby girls in this
room right now but when we're done here
she going back and nobody in the
rainforest what I think would be cool is
if you started like a blog about all
your favorite plants yeah blog you could
do it on Squarespace calm and so could
Julie like your favorite hobby you go to
squarespace.com slash annejulien save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain and you can start building a
website it's a really great platform
take Jennifer example she wanted to make
a blog yes I said blog with her about
her plants and in her journey as a plant
person she could do that very easily
there's a lot of different templates you
can choose from Squarespace there's 24/7
customer support they make it so you can
customize your website to look a certain
way on desktop mobile or your tablets we
have our current gen and Julien website
on Squarespace we love Squarespace it
makes building a website and achieving
your vision of having an online presence
in the form of a website very easy and
the best part is like it looks good and
it's not really that hard to do you can
also start with a free trial but the
24/7 customer support is just to die for
its award-winning customer support they
want you to make your website exactly
how you want it so click the link down
below and check it out whether it's a
business or a hobby whatever you want to
build the website for check it out I
think it's worth doing and then when you
build a website tweeted at us we love
seeing your websites you guys build some
cool stuff also guys if you want to look
good and stay stylin and feel great and
maybe match with your significant other
or friend
get some me at ease it's like the
perfect solution to all of those things
it's amazing underwear my underwear
drawer is literally nothing but me and
he's at this point they're onesies Jeff
was wearing head-to-toe me and these the
other day I have a bra let the underwear
socks and my onesie on I have socks on
right now and yeah they truly have like
an incredible material that they use for
all their stuff but they have new prints
coming out with their underwear and
their onesies all the time
festive prints they st. Patrick's Day
whatever you whatever you desire in
terms of style or they have simple
colors if you want to keep it you know
toned down a little bit you're like okay
well Julian that's a lot for me I'm an
adult well if you're an adult you know
get it get a solid color you don't have
to yell at me about it also we can all
just have different different opinions
about things and get along while we do
it and also be wearing me on these
mandis is a proud sponsor of the podcast
and me Andy's also supports us like
outside of the bar gasps which is really
nice
they're like constantly tweeting at me
and like they're so sweet such a great
team over there anyway save 15% off your
first purchase of me undies free
shipping and 100% satisfaction guarantee
go to meet a nice calm slash Julian or
click the link below you will not be
disappointed thank you
alright sorry about that anyways my
plant obsession started out very slowly
and then true-life it turned into
something that's a little out of control
and it will continue to get out of
control until I gain soon we're not
gonna have our green screen back here
soon the plants so I found out that you
could order plants online oh yeah here
we go this is this is the beginning at
the end I think there's a place called
low jeez that ships what's the only
place I've ordered from there's many
places but low jeez is in Connecticut so
if you live in North America it's a
place that I've had luck ordering from I
also happen to live in a place where
like it's not the dead of winter so like
they have ship
plants to me with a little heating pad
in it but I think there are things that
they won't ship and states that they
won't ship to until it's nice or out
which I've also read is a better time to
buy your plants anyways Here I am just
being like it's Jenny where you don't
give a [ __ ] um so like this plant this
is a begonia I think you say maculata
yti and when I saw this plant I just
could not believe it like there's I have
a allocation of fry deck downstairs like
the first time that you see some of
these plants it took my [ __ ] breath
away
like I just have never seen anything
like it there's [ __ ] spots on it and
don't chance it's invisible right now
but the backs of it is red and then just
to make things [ __ ] crazier it blooms
yeah it grows these beautiful little
flowers if given the right conditions
and it's just like it blows my mind and
you can live in my house why and how
[ __ ] what are you doing here I love it
this is a this is a real breathtaker
place yeah when I saw this plant I was
like I will do anything I will do
anything for you I like [ __ ] I'm at
your service which is why we have two
humidifiers to be fair though it has
been much better because we used to wake
up with sore throats because the air is
very dry and it does start till the
filter work yeah it helps us sleep
better and stuff and that room is gonna
stay under control because only the
plants that need humidity are going in
there and there's limited space I can't
get out of control it is the rainforest
plus it's also like that I worry about
this plant I worry about her constantly
I'm worried if she's getting enough
humidity if the door is staying closed
if the dogs are coming in and out
somebody shut the [ __ ] door because
the humidity needs to stay you know what
I'm saying I worry about her and I don't
I don't want to do that all the time
that's why getting a plant like this has
made me love and appreciate my Zizi
plants my snake plants the ones that are
requires zero they need nothing you give
them nothing and they give you so much
love energy plant and the snake they add
those there's easy plant hasn't seen any
sunlight close it's like in the middle
of our house
our living room yeah on the other side
of it right and dropping new leaves
everyday like he's just dropping crap
out like it's nobody's business yeah
that it's really rewarding to have a
place like that which is why I think at
first I was like mmm that plants not
that cool but like yeah it's gonna live
here and that's great so but I have
grown to love and appreciate how much
love they show you without giving them
anything it's pretty great yeah it's
yeah it's it's nice that you like took
the leap but you did it slowly you got
your feet wet and then you started to
pick up steam and I like that you've
kind of gotten into this selfishly
because I'm reaping the benefits of
having wonderful plants everywhere and
also it's not to take care of any water
no not really but also I'm learning a
lot too about not only the plants and
the specific species of plants but also
just like what it takes to have plants
in your house and I mean the amount of
effort the amount of planning and what
you can gain from it like we were
talking about that that room they were
talking about downstairs earlier it
looks really great and it would not look
even close to like that well it's a it's
a tough room because it's north-facing
windows so like not very good light I'm
sure a lot of you can [ __ ] relate
like you just have these rooms in your
house and you're like I would love this
to look pretty but like it just doesn't
have good light or it has like one small
window there's a big window but there's
a overhang out front there's a lot of
trees and bushes out there and it's
North facing so there's just not a lot
of light and I would love it to be nice
but I've decided I was gonna fill it
with some plants that really like that
low light so we got a lot of snake plans
some Zizi plants and I have had trouble
with my pothos although to be fair I
repotted him and then he wasn't doing
well so then I repotted the repotting
yeah and then he peaced the [ __ ] on
paper the pathos should not be giving
you this much trouble it's the only plan
I've struggled with it was just that one
yeah anyway we're after this we're on
our way to go get some more bottles so
yes because I have a vision [ __ ] and
we're like we're adding to that little
patio outside of that room and yeah so
good right so here's the thing yeah so
this is a [ __ ] rabbit hole that's
literally never-ending and I need to
control myself
which is why I like okay you're here I
love you there's like a couple planets
where I'm like I really want that one
yeah but then let's not do this like go
on Instagram and look at every planet
and decide that we need all of them like
you were doing last night
I was not deciding I needed all of them
you just have a very rare there's one
plant that I want that I can't find
because it just like it doesn't exist so
rare Pokemon it's not that rare it's
just like they don't sell it in the
United States right people that that
have plants they'll sell cuttings which
I thought was insane yeah it was just
like you know snip a leaf and then sell
it to you for ten or fifteen dollars in
a ziplock bag and I'm like that's crazy
what are you supposed to do it well you
propagate it you put it in water you put
it in soil so it starts rooting so then
you know there's a chance that it just
doesn't take it all and now you've spent
ten dollars and waited you know a week
for this little plant in his lock bag to
get to you like how lazy can you please
root it for me and I'll pay a little
more money so I can have a [ __ ] plate
so if you were to get in the plans that
get-rich-quick scheme cutting I would I
would do anything I want that planet
well tell them what it is in case
someone has that Columbia I think well
part of the problem was I was trying to
find the actual exact name but it's hard
because well there's this girl that I
liked on YouTube named Kaylee Ellen and
she makes rare plant index videos she
says that sounds like piss she sounds
like pansy she reminds me of pansy she's
really relaxing she really likes plants
she's relaxing and reminds you to see
like what kinds of plant people are
drawn to like a lot of people like
philodendron she really likes coal a
Thea's like i don't it's really fine i
like holy is that you whatever it's
really cute
she likes cool ideas and strumming at
these but those ones aren't for me but I
still really like watching her she does
a rare plant index video and you can you
can see even she struggles with like
it's just hard to tell what plants are
what like there's no pictures of them
they'll have maybe an 8 you just which
is why her videos are interesting
because I was looking on Wikipedia right
for this specific name of this plan the
best that I could come up with was
Columbia gloriosa purpurea or superba
but I'm not sure it's basically a
goldfish plant which is readily
available here the
REME kind with these like little
goldfish looking flowers which are super
cute but the one that I'm looking for
has these like dark purpley fuzzy leaves
super it like hang sounds super far and
at the bottom has these like spectacular
red flowers that go like this hello it
looks where is this plant version why
can't I ever cook and find I would pay a
sketchy person on Etsy you know $20 for
a cutting of that just so I could take
it home and see if I could route it it's
a dope looking plant it looks like a
plant from a different planet cuz it's
like it's black it's like a black planet
I love it it's beautiful no but it's
very cool that's that's a plant that I
want but probably can't find so I'm just
you know I'm not gonna get another plant
because I can't find it you know
whatever but anyways something that I've
learned that is helpful is if you decide
the the light that you have first and
then decide on a plant after is much
better than getting a plant and then
being like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I need
so much more Sun that I have yeah
panicking and having put it like on the
window yeah but I mean we have the sheer
curtains in front of most of our windows
which helps a lot because breaks up the
light a little bit yeah most planets
can't have just like beaming sunlight
down I want to get a prickly pear I want
to get a big old cactus well you're in
luck because we live in a great place to
grow a cacti outdoors we could grow them
indoors but we can also grow out don't
want a big old prickly pear I want to
put them a Jeep which is currently
filled with dirt because of all the
plans we've been buying no don't be
sorry that's why I got a jeep well got a
jeep to transport your plants anyways
I'm still a super beginner though
because these are all indoor house
plants and as summer comes around I want
to go outdoors work on the outdoors
which is a whole I have no idea how to
do that yeah I'm gonna be a whole new
learning curve out there too but I think
we're getting our feet wet nicely with
that little patio because we can get a
couple things for outdoors that can
survive right now like a prickly pear
maybe or like a
I know you're talking about having
certainly I want to yeah because you
could grow them people have them all
over here in Southern California you can
grow such which is like to me oh my god
are you [ __ ] kidding me oh my god we
can only grow apples [ __ ] we got citrus
out here oh my god we can only grow
[ __ ] apples and they're ready and
fault and only fall save them okay okay
anyway so if you go upstate New York and
you eat some apples
I'm sorry although their apples pale in
comparison I was talking about like how
avocados know you have an apple first
right right right right now I'm done a
dead don't you guys have like an apple
fast I don't know you don't have an
apple fest you have a flower fest in
Rochester lilac lilac festival if I was
apple apples well I mean we have plenty
of places to get apples you do apple
picking I've taken you to my hometown
many times what Santa Monica yes and
you've never taken me yours okay we
should go to the lilac fest it's in the
spring probably probably like May for
March I don't know something that starts
with an M except probably not March I
can't remember if it's like early spring
early spring is it Monday
yes Monday okay anyways I really like my
plants but I'm doing okay
I'm doing pretty good I've had a couple
that where like I bought a plant from
Home Depot that was I don't know what
the [ __ ] they did to that poor plant man
they made it soaking wet they put it in
a pot that it couldn't breathe it was
[ __ ] up mm-hmm that's another thing
you're finding out like you'll buy
plants from certain weird places
like maybe a Humvee but maybe Lowe's
whatever and you find out it's just been
like so poorly taken care of her like
repotted in the wrong way or wrong size
mm-hmm which is upsetting but yeah what
you buy the monstera
again at Lowe's right they repotted oh
my god he's still struggling I mean he's
doing okay now he's totally fine that
plant is a beast like they'll just do
whatever yeah it's a you know it's a
trendy instagrammy plant it's a monster
at deliciosa and they're beautiful but
somebody [ __ ] put this plant in like
a ceramic pot and he was soaking
so I took him home and I was like okay
I'm not gonna water you until your soil
is dry so I'm just monitoring him every
day with my little meter
it's just sopping wet for like two and a
half weeks and I'm like that's it it's a
rescue mission we're getting you out of
here good to repot him but then he
suffered because he was repotted man it
was a lot that poor guy he's doing
better now yes he's on the mend
um but yeah somebody done did that
planet dirty or like this like you know
we found a nursery around here that's
family-owned amazing I love them
but like some of the plants because they
have like so many and they're all kept
outside you know some of them just they
they're a little wonky but I'd rather
have a plant like that and it's
character was like he was such a
wonderful reasonable price and I like
supporting those people or any
family-owned business I really I really
so much prefer that nursery to like a
big chain nursery yeah yeah I love them
but yeah it's it can get totally [ __ ]
out of hand
mm-hmm well because we have a lot of
rooms and a lot of light and I have
opportunities to put plants places a lot
of desire afraid to look like a jungle
mm-hmm mm-hmm okay
yeah well jungle it up and you know do
you think I'm worried though if we go
out of town they're all gonna die no
they're not because you like on paper uh
it'd take one week you don't really do a
lot in terms of like aside from like
checking them but like you're not
watering them every day you're not no no
but like Kaylee Ellen says that [ __ ]
that Alocasia she calls it an eight-mile
plant cuz you got one shot to water him
he starts Wilton you either water him
and then he's good or he goes goodbye
[ __ ] and then he leans over like that
hmm I need to double-check that that's
her name he could not call me her well
yeah oh I think he's talked about the
plant I don't think I was gonna say I
don't think the plant would mine if you
call it the wrong
how location Ellen I watch a lot of
plant youtubers I love plant arena or
like a health and Carter you don't know
any of these people are do you know hold
on do you want to hear her voice Jillian
yes she sounds like pansy yeah no she's
not yelling at me she's not flaming you
let's take it let's take a gander I'm
like subscribed to her hello plant tube
be like it it's really cute there's like
yeah Kaylee Ellen right
okay anyway sorry
yeah don't watch those videos if you
like plants because you'll see these
plants that exist that you can't get so
it's hard that's how I feel about the
Columbia gloriosa but the moment you
find something that you can't get it's
like okay I'm getting that plant you
can't get it oh oh you just wait you
can't get it I'm sorry but I disagree
there's so many plants that exists like
in tropical jungles just if you go on
Wikipedia and you start clicking on them
and in looking up their names like you
can't get those things you can grow them
in a greenhouse like in a plant
conservatory I'm gonna do what you got
to do even then I'm the king of finding
things far away online that I'm not
supposed to be able to get and getting
them that is true you you got that
Japanese IG works when they weren't
selling anywhere to sell you a
turtleneck I've had a lot of success
with Japan I bought a mask well actually
sort of back in my baseball base I
shopped on Nike JP instead of the Nike
u.s. store because they sold things that
I literally couldn't ever buy just a
little extra shipping just don't tell
Mom and then get a couple don't tell mom
so insane like when I was younger there
was no such thing as like ordering
things I should have been anyway I
really like I really like my plants but
as I've gotten ones that need more love
and care which is nice because as a
person that likes your plants you
constantly I'm like oh my god needs
something from me you know they need me
I love you I want to take care of you
it's really nice to have maybe one or
two plants like that and then there are
two permits and them are like I'm fine
yeah you know but it took me a minute to
appreciate the ones that are like I'm
good yeah true that's true
mm-hmm it is nice we've got a nice thing
going yeah houses looking green well and
it's just like oh one thing I didn't
realize about plants until I started
having plants was like I thought you
sort of just get a plant and then you
put it in its spot and then it lives
there forever TM sometimes you got to
move them if it's winter they need more
light and we have sort of like mini
nurseries set up for the new plants to
to like get good light well yeah so they
can get acclimated and stuff but like
you know it's like I'm constantly just
like moving plants around and being like
oh maybe you'll get better light here or
you know if he's not doing well in this
spot maybe I'll move them to this spot
yeah you know which I have some choices
there but yeah I mean it's on an endless
supply of Windows it was like it's
starting to get a little crowded in
spots you know yeah we'll just we'll
keep an eye on it you only get to
Crowder but it has made me deeply
appreciate like all the cool plants that
you like needs bright indirect light
which I always thought meant okay I'll
take you outside here you go that's wait
how courage had to eat your plan
we didn't though okay so here is one
thing so I did not know that a lot of
house plants are toxic to animals yeah
but like marbled peach even Kermit
they're not interested in the plants
whatsoever yeah
and I've also read information about how
you shouldn't sleep in a bedroom with
any plants in it but like something
about the you know when the the light
isn't there then they're not making
oxygen they're making carbon
oh no carbon dioxide yes something's but
like you you would get more of that from
sleeping next to a person so okay I say
thanks to a person who you're making
more of it than the plants are whatever
yeah you sleep next to a person I don't
know whatever there's some weird stuff
yeah I've also seen people like angrily
comment on other people's videos like oh
my god don't sleep with plants any room
you're gonna die okay I mean that seems
like a little bit ridiculous but I don't
know me something um they're not
interested in the plants but it is the
thing like if you had a cat for example
like some cats will try and chew like
he's not gonna chew on it yeah but I had
my Hoya outside one of them who has this
like really spectacular like tendril
growing up because that's how they grow
in some of them and then they'll put the
flower out at the end of that but um it
was just sitting up and I was I had him
outside because he's in a hanging basket
and he I need him to dry before I put
him back on his little wooden stool
mm-hmm and um so I was just sitting
outside with him you know looking at I'm
checking on his new little leaves having
a good time hermit walks up and just
puts that long tendril just in his mouth
and then looks at me like [ __ ] [ __ ]
I was like permit carmit he just did it
to piss you off because you weren't
loving him you were loving a plan well
it's like how if you remember in our old
place we had a drink on the table with a
straw and I caught him just walking up
to it and like chewing on it and then
looking at me like if something is
sticking out at him he'll chew on it
just to sort of like piss you off you
know that's the only time I've seen him
be interested in anyone nasty boy but
yeah if you had it I think it's you know
cats or a curious dog and yeah so yeah
not good but anyways I have a problem
only it's a problem I think it's
honestly I'm excited that you've become
so interested in plants because I think
as far as hobbies go this is probably
like the least harmful one the most
healthy it can get expensive aside from
that you know I mean this is it's I feel
like it's a cool thing especially to
watch
like you know living in the same house
like we get I get the benefits of it so
it's nice yeah you do a lot of new
plants get a lot of green I get a lot of
good looking rooms and it's been a fun
like project to transform rooms and
stuff but I honestly think that like the
Dinks really appreciate you talking
about the plants because I've liked
non-stop gotten comments in chat like I
want you to go that absolutely love
plants and I get it you know like I it's
so easy to just have a plant and decide
you love it and then be like oh my god
that plan exists what is that I need
that one what is that what is that like
ordering plants online dangerous but
yeah I would
at some point do like a plant tour
probably like on my main channel but I
kind of want to wait till you know yeah
for sure things will like this see we
have a I'm sorry I can't speak but like
we have a full like array of Sun so like
right now all the plants are in their
winter spots pretty much but after a
full season I'd like to see have an idea
of where they can live so they can
thrive have some good growth in the
spring you know so I'm not showing you
plants that I've had for two weeks
and yeah they're alive but where I show
you where they are what kind of light
they're getting is not correct we'll
wait you know what I mean yeah we'll
wait till it's the right time to do it
yeah and um yeah I'd love to show you
guys my plants because I love them so
much they really just make me feel a lot
yeah they're nice they're so relaxing
thank you for sharing them with us on
the podcast welcome we should make some
plants up here for the podcast room you
have like beautiful plants but this
again is the north-facing windows we may
struggle but there's no overhang so you
get more like that's true you know what
I'm saying
well thank you guys for hanging out
hopefully you enjoyed Jonas plants sorry
Geoff is annoying audio plant tour no
this is really interesting and I think a
lot of people probably wanted to hear it
so actually I know a lot of you wanted
to hear well okay here's what I will say
if you wanna get up
and you're not sure and you're scared as
long as you have some sort of daylight
coming into a room I'd say get a snake
plant or a zz plant
Charlie you just can't really go wrong
there very low-maintenance yeah barely
need water but it will help your air
especially like I wish that I had a
plant when I lived in a dorm because I
really wanted like anything to take care
of and can't have anything I don't know
if they'll let you have like a little
plant and a dorm but if they did like a
snake plant or a zz plant is perfect
because you have something to care for
something little they consider your desk
that's living you know nice help clean
your air like I didn't know a single
person in our dorm that had a plant no I
don't think I did either right I didn't
like living in a dorm I didn't like
living in a dorm the other anyways
anyways I thought you guys were hanging
out we'll see you next week for another
podcast and we'll see all week on stream
special shout out to the ding family
hangs out orange which shall we hit six
thousand subs last week and you guys are
blowing our minds with the support over
there so if you haven't checked out
twitch stream is a lot of fun we stream
like for five to eight hours each night
mostly except for Wednesdays and we play
all games and hang out and drink so
check it out it's in the description but
thank you guys and I will see you in
seven days we need to pour her back in
the humidity you know okay time to bring
her back to the room thank you
[Music]